une autre activité qui s'ouvre à
l'international c'est l'ULM ce week-end
la Fédération française compte 16
licenciés certains le pratiquent tout
près d'ici à l'aérodrome de Blois Le
Breuil il débutait aujourd'hui le salon
mondial de l'ULM c'est 12 pays
représentés et plus de 800 machines de
toutes les époques présentes en vol ou
au sol dont des autogire une invention
mise à l'honneur cette année car elle
fait ses 100 ans reportage de clémence
dausques
moteur décollage pour cette 42e édition
du Mondial de l'ULM parmi les six
classes de ces motorisés l'autogire les
passionnés les plus piqués le mettent à
l'honneur pour son anniversaire
l'autogire il a 100 ans et depuis ces 10
dernières années il y a de plus en plus
d'autogire d'ailleurs sur le salon on
parle on dit qu'on devient autogyradique
dès qu'on y monte on ne redescend plus
inventer en 1923 par l’ingénieur
espagnol Juan de la Sierra l'autogire
est un type d'Ulm avec une voiture
tournante la différence avec un
hélicoptère son rotor n'est pas motorisé
le rotor qui est au-dessus et bien
tourne absolument tout seul du décollage
jusqu'à l'atterrissage le moteur il sert
à quoi il sert à prélancer avant le
décollage et il sert également ensuite à
faire monter la machine pour atteindre
une certaine altitude puis rester à une
certaine altitude avec un certain régime
moteur le vent brasse la plaine de
l'aérodrome des conditions qui
n'empêchent pas les autogire de voler la
patrouille des 100 ans de cette ULM
s'envole pour une démonstration
atterrissage en douceur avant de laisser
la place au suivant pour piloter cet
engin un brevet est nécessaire on peut
le passer à partir de 16 ans
quand on est dans notre machine et voilà
on est à la tête dans les nuages ça fait
du bien les démonstrations vous
continuez tout ce week-end aérogire
pendule et autres aéronef son pari au
décollage
[Musique]